et si comme Faustine vous aimez la
pétanque un grand tournoi se déroule
tout le weekend à tour et ça débutait
aujourd'hui 128 terrains dans le parc
des expositions la tourangel apétanque
attend 3000 joueurs sur 3 jours dont une
quarantaine d'équipes qui joue au niveau
international alors le gros de la
compétition aura lieu demain mais
aujourd'hui l'événement ouvrait avec le
tournoi des vétérans les plus de 60 ans
et là aussi il y a du niveau romain
Delville était sur place la tour el à
pétanque en chiffre ce sont 160 terrains
tracés 60 tonnes de gravier et de sable
plus de 3000 compétiteurs et
compétitrice sur le weekend et le
chiffre du jour c'est 60 comme l'âge
minimum des boulistes le Parc Expo et le
boulodrome sont jusque dimanche des
repères de passionnés de boules j'ai
beaucoup joué en famille avec mon oncle
j'ai signé ma première licence de pétan
à 12
ans
et j'ai toujours joué en en fait hein
c'est c'est c'est un sport un jeu qui
m'a toujours plu bon j'ai jamais joué
beaucoup beaucoup mais bon j'ai je
prends plaisir à jouerin et d'autant
plus maintenant je suis à la retraite je
vais un petit peu plus souvent à
l'entraînement qu'avant voilà
Jean-Claude est venu cette année en
spectateur mais en bon bouliste averti
il aiguise son regard de technicien je
regarde plus le terrain pour les don les
donn des joueurs pour voir s'il donnent
bien la la boule avec les DV parce que
il y a du dév ça paraît pas mais il y a
des DV alors je regarde comment il
pointent parce que les tireurs bon ils
ont pas besoin de de terrain il tap les
boules sur les 256 triplettes du tournoi
vétéran nombreuses sont celles qui
seront spectatrices le reste du weekend
avec en point d'org le National du
samedi et la présence de plusieurs
champions du
monde